congressman james Clyburn who is a
number three leader of the House
Democrats told us that black voters need
to stand up and be counted on Saturday
why is black turnout so important I
think it's because the black community
has I think the obligation to let people
know what is in their heart and their
heads you don't do that
by following the results of our New
Hampshire or Nevada you do that by
voting for the candidate that bless best
address what's in your heart and what's
in your head and not chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett is here
along with Democratic strategist and CBS
News political political contributor
Jamal Simmons is his name he worked for
President Bill Clinton and advised
President Barack Obama's 2008 campaign
welcome to you both can water hail Jamal
I'm gonna start with you because we want
to start with President bite in the
Palmetto State yes where his lead is
slipping among black voters why is that
happening and it's it's slipping
significantly in a very short amount of
time why do you think that's happen you
know a lot of Joe Biden's support came
from black voters who were over the age
of 40 right over the age of 45 so to
some of the most pragmatic Americans
that there are in the entire country and
they're looking for somebody who can
beat Donald Trump it's hard to make the
argument if you've been losing two or
three weeks in a row that you're the
best person to win come November so I
think those voters are looking for
another champion the question is where
do they go and right now I think that's
a tough question to answer where do they
end up some have gone with Tom Steyer
but there's still a great number who up
for grabs for the first time I saw Tom
Steyer commercials that I haven't seen
in a very long time he's running a lot
of commercials here and in the polls
he's doing well yeah he is doing very
well in the polls he has in this state
Biden says that that's the reason
perhaps why he's not he's not winning
yeah you know there may be other reasons
vice-president not winning is why he's
not winning
exactly major let's talk about Bernie
Sanders had a big weekend in Nevada
actually you know when you use the word
momentum you can think about Bernie
Sanders has he officially become assume
frontrunner status or is it still way
too so there's a corollary corollary to
not winning is why you're not winning
winning is why you're winning winning
begets winning you create a sense of
momentum and you tell voters early on
I've identified these states there's a
crowded field and I keep winning Bernie
Sanders can see that on the popular vote
in Iowa and everywhere else about it and
New Hampshire that sends a signal that
the movement is strong his fundraising
is more powerful than anyone and it's a
grassroots fundraising mechanism all of
those things send signals to voters and
will be fascinating here in South
Carolina is that signal strong enough to
overcome the embedded resistance to a
socialist Democrat in a place like South
Carolina is he attracting do you guys
think more of the moderate vote well it
is certainly something that has been a
bit gravitated to him Nevada is the
first place where that was actually a
visible in either the entrance polls are
some of the conversations with voters
after that and South Carolina and then
Super Tuesday will be a test of that
across the board you know Gail what
normally happens is as the insurgent
candidate begins to catch fire the
moderates and the establishment begin to
find their way to him the difference is
Bernie Sanders is still declaring war on
the Democratic establishment as much as
he is on the president United States but
I don't know the answer to is can he
both fight the Democratic Party and the
president and win both of those fights
all right Jamal and major thank you very
much